very honored to be here
closing our PI data called aura and I
have a great time these past three days
and congratulations to you all or
surviving the conference so I hope you
survive this talk as well because I
think I would probably go all the time
so to start first just a little bit
about myself so I actually started out
as a psychologist study is a
psychologist and at the time I
exclusively use SPSS and then and then
afterward I kind of slightly changed
field two to study in my PhD I do
research on kind of cognitive psychology
and I look in mostly on like how mission
high human wish don't work so basically
how we recognize faces objects by
employing techniques like I movement eg
and fmi and I also changed my to lean a
little bit started used quite often
MATLAB and at a time I start to grow a
strong interest of these kind of
permutations and a number call approach
which kind of like introduced me to
Bayesian and I started to also move on
my works into Python and PI data kind of
this ecosystems and I especially
interesting I MCMC methods kind of lie
continues of my love of bootstrap and
permutations and around a year a little
bit more than a year ago I changed my
career again and switch to industries on
currently I'm a data scientist in Google
working mostly on user trust and working
in trust and safety mostly kind of like
protecting users make sure that the
platform screen on Google and today I
will talk about how to improve
a patient or public library in Python so
first some disclaimer although I worked
quite closely with tensorflow and
transferability team my opinion does not
I'm not a spokesperson for them I don't
represent them and also I'm not also a
software engineer so I would be talking
about log about implementing writing
software but it's more from kind of my
personal experience as a data scientist
and as a PMC developer so we'll first go
through for today just a quick outline
will first go through some basic
building blocks of writing down a
patient model for example what we will
need for implementing probabilistic
library and also I would mostly focus on
how it's currently done in piracy free
and why we need to kind of find a new
approach for the for primacy for moving
forward and I also touch a little bit
around this concept called effect
handling for example life is mostly
about when you write program how you
handle the cipher correctly so that you
get what you're actually intended for
and as some expected takeaways be able
to write your own patient library is not
one of them
instead I hope that it will give you
some better understanding of how a
probabilistic library is implemented so
that in a waste when you write down your
own patient model or probabilistic
models you now have a better understand
all house I should debug it and
basically also a better strategy in
terms of when you are changing your
model or when you read some calls of
other people implemented model you have
a better understanding of all why did
they do it this way and if I want to
change how can I make sure that is
running correctly so right patient model
I actually will not keep any
introduction on Bayesian modeling so
but in just a really really high level
we can think of our oil data that we are
trying to analyze trying to model is
from some generative process for example
if you look at the first figure here we
can think of that you have this observed
data it's just coming in as well one
dimension re and if you do a histogram
you have this kind of shape and actually
this this data is generated from a
mixture kind of distribution so in kind
of light of key thinking here is that
you have some observed data and they are
actually generated from some random
process and we try to capture try to
write program to capture this generative
process and kind of like the main tag
lie of being a Bayesian is that not only
we are thinking of the data we are
observing as coming from some generative
process but also the parameters so all
the parameter we are trying to model a
bit for it as for example if you look at
linear regressions or some scatter plots
on on the right
not only we can think of it is a
generative kind of lie from some
generative process that is linear we can
also think of the parameter in this
model for example the coefficients the
intercept they are also coming from some
distributions so this kind of like the
general idea of why we wanted to patient
modeling and how we can think of our
data as from some patient model and you
might have seen some representation or
patient models such as the following in
general is a very expressive
representation and has been a patient we
lie to claim that you can write on any
model of being a patient model and you
sometimes you you might recognize some
these kind of notations so if you go lie
by lie it means that you have some
parameters is
kind of from Gaussian prior and you also
have a another parameter from a half
normal or half Gaussian prior it means
that this parameter will only define
four numbers that are positive and then
you have some operation here and then at
the end this is your observations so
again this experience this model here
explains linear regressions that we just
see and you can also represent it in
another way of this kind of graphical
model and in this way it's kind of spell
out the dependency more more directory
so this is actually some of the graphs
that you can generate when you're using
pi MC free so you can just draw the
graph and here what it tells you it
actually has some additional information
for example here it tells you there's a
hundred observations and there's also a
linear transformation
although the tilde is not strictly
correct because it's the deterministic
transformation so on a very high level
an ideal patient library library should
provide a consistent or what I what I'd
like to call a no surprise API to
express this kind of model and we can
get useful information from them so what
kind of information we want to get from
a patient model here would be some
typical things that I or any kinds of
people to in analysis might want to see
for example we want to identify what are
the unknown parameters in my models I
want to generate a posterior
distributions you sometimes call it a
loss function when you're doing
optimizations and this we will use that
for our inference and the point here is
that sometimes not only we want the full
posterior sometimes we want make for
example a conditional one or my imaginal
ones which means that some of the
dimension actually we treated as
different than the others and we might
also want to evaluate a function over
the posterior distribution
and these are in general the cases when
you have objective function and you want
to use the posterior to make decision
for example if you knows that the
Hurricanes how how likely it will call
its going to hit the city and you have
an objective function or if it does hit
the city how much loss we have and
whether we should evacuate the city and
these things you eat formally you it
would be can be described as applying
this objective function over the
posterior distribution and usually in
practice will try to sample from the
posterior and use Monte Carlo sample to
as a representation of the posterior and
last we also want to have to get a
conditional probability and use that to
do random number generation this our use
case for example you want to do
posterior predictive sample which means
after you fit the model you want to see
that how how it look how the uncertainty
around observation is giving the model
that you just fit and yeah and a bit
more and if I kind of summarize all the
things that I typically typically
typically do on a Bayesian model we can
kind of think of it in two way so one of
the way is that we run the program
forward of this kind of forward
generated all simulations basically what
it means here would be with similarly
from the prior we plug it in into the
into any kinds of functions and then we
have masked the likelihood or the
distribution for the opposite data and
then we generate the kind of defect data
and the other way to think about it of
the things we want to do or when we want
to get from a Bayesian model is this
kind of backward inference or we want to
get the likelihood or the log function
and this is usually means that we
actually have some observations and we
want to inference the unknown parameters
so basically the information is kind of
floating from backward to the top so now
the first pass
you have to do is of course we want to
translate this model that we write on a
piece of paper into something that a
computer recognize and can run so let's
try the first kind of identify the
operations and see how straightforward
it would be to implement it so the first
things that we can kind of see is this
number eco computations so there are a
lot of it's kind of like straightforward
because in the Python data science or a
Python date PI data ecosystem we have
lots of scientific computation tools we
have light classical line numpy side PI
and we also have things that comes with
gradient light ends of rho pi taj and so
on and for example here we will see that
we have a matrix multiplications and we
have additions so that's kind of like
one of the among some of the common
operation we want to do or functions we
can apply and usually for for any kinds
of numerical computation tools or
library that we are using it comes with
some reference representation of data
type and for example you can have fro 32
Ari
or you have tensor which is a dimension
high dimensional array although the
definition is debatable sometimes if you
talk to mathematicians and also you have
collections of light domain-specific
toolbox that is Bill Upton upon the this
kind of more elementary number call
computation tools so that you can have
like complicated function
transformations another next thing is
that we can identify other distributions
so probability probability distribution
we I'm not going to go into detail level
is the formal definitions but in high
level on high level we can understand
this is something associated with a
random variable and usually comes with
probability function is either a CDF or
PDF which means that you can evaluate
on kind of rail accumulated probability
or the you have a probability density
function that you can evaluate on some
inputs and it also most of the time it
comes with some random number
generations so you can generate random
number quite efficiently right so the
last piece is kind of like the most
difficult is the random variables and
the reason of it being difficult is that
it's actually not really well-defined if
you actually try to write down some
program for example inside pi so I will
skip the definition for now
and let's just look at how sigh pi is
kind of define what a random variable
and we try to use that to express this
probabilistic or dissipation model so
inside by the stats module provides lots
of distributions and if you look at the
talks training it actually say that they
defines a random variable so for example
here there's talk strings for the normal
distribution but actually it says it's a
it's a continuous random variable so
yeah let's go ahead and try to use it
and see what happens so now I what I
would do is I would start writing out
this program kind of translating this
patient program into a patient model
into a program so for time I just give
you some random data and then I write I
spell out all the distributions now the
error happens when I try to plug that in
into a linear equation or any kinds of
functions because it will complains that
the type is actually not supported
because you cannot multiply kind of like
a non pyari or this re data type with a
random variable a frozen one random
variable so it turns out that dependent
the operations of any kinds of numerical
method actually only defines on some
specific data type and if the data type
is not kind of compatible you cannot
propagate your program and this kind of
light down to the core of why it's
difficult
to implementation model because it
actually changed the value of the
representation of a random variable in
actual computation it changed depending
on what things we want from it so in a
ways that depend on what mode we are
running the program is executed
differently so by what I mean is that we
can look back at what we asked what we
started out of like things we want from
a patient model so we want to do this
forward generations and we want to have
this backward inference a loss function
or posterior distribution that you can
evaluate on now so if you want to have a
program that actually runs inside pi you
actually write this way so here it's
kind of lights do the same so you define
you kind of float you have a frozen
random variables but if you want to plug
that in into linear functions actually
you want you need to draw some numbers
so which means that now you have some
realization of these distributions and
after you do this draw this random
number this now is some number
Ares so you can do multiplication you
can plug it into a function you can do
things it's just like what you normally
do right
and also for generating the kind of this
prior predicted a distribution or some
simulated data we also need to do the
samples on the livelihood or other
distributions that define our observed
data now in a river small that is a bit
different we still have the distribution
kind of defined it the same way but now
we actually need a function because all
the unknowns say we want to evaluate
they are we actually don't have the
actual number yet so basically we need
to give it some kinds of placeholder and
the best way to represent it of course
is a function because
we can plot it into any kinds of inputs
and now because these are implicitly
they are they need should be something
that they can you can do computations or
you can multiply you can do the dot you
can do the matrix multiplications you
need two additions so they actually
needs to be some kinds of numpy Ari's in
this context and then you actually also
run it differently in a way that you are
not doing simulation but you are pulling
out the crust method which is the lock
lock lock and then you compute it
evaluate on the numbers that the user
input so that's kind of like the main
challenge so we have the kind of the
numbers that we want to propagate in
this in this program come to this point
the number actually comes from different
places so they in a forward kind of mode
they are coming from some random draw of
the distributions and in a backward
computation mode they are coming from
some user inputs and we you might be you
might say that oh actually we can just
combine thing together and you can write
this huge call basically depending on
the context so for example all the user
wants to have some forward model and we
do something different if the user have
a backward mole we do something else and
now this program will be fine because
you can just initialize this this kind
of function to generate another function
and you can use this color balls to do
simulations or to use it as log drop
functions and of course this is really
unsatisfying especially when you look at
the code you see all all these are
completely the same so why can we not
just combine them together and this kind
of line the things that we want to
achieve in a good patient library is
that we want to compile a combine these
two process into a coherent API so which
comes
this is our challenge of sorry which
means that we need some kinds of
placeholder they should just add like an
umpire re or any kinds of tensor
depending on the background you're using
and you should be able to kind of swap
out the values underneath depending on
the context
so again if the user is running this
forward mode then we would do a sample
from distributions and then plug that in
and if user actually surprising this
these values then we just use those
values so what are the solutions of
course the no plain brainer is that you
use some you ask the user to provide
this log posterior distribution directly
to you so which means that the user if
they won a simulation a simulator they
write simulator and provide it to the
library and if they won a log prop
function they write spell out a lot of
function themselves and this is actually
some of the approach some a
probabilistic library used for example
EMC is you need to provide a lot of
functions also if you use low level tens
of roll a probability you also need to
do the same and the process that now we
don't need to borrow anything as a
provisional library is easier than ever
but the cons of course you rely on the
use of the do the right things and
writing this thing twice is at best kind
of tedious and at worst buggy because
user might provide inconsistent programs
there's the implementations that not the
same in the two but it's very difficult
to validate so what is another self
solutions so another solution is this
idea called a difference which means
that user write on a program but we
don't execute it yet and depending on
the context we were executed and we
reuse the value that depending on the
context and this is what essentially the
attention for distribution of attention
probability Joint Distribution does for
example in joint distribution sequential
you provide a sequence of a distribution
lambda functions and given that they can
be initialized depending on context now
when people are asking for a lot like a
lot prop then they just regenerate a lot
of plot on the fly and also this is what
the ten-time see for pollute I - we -
doing so we actually draw a lot of
inspiration from the Joint Distribution
co-routine and the cool thing of here
now is that you have a really coherent
framework for example for tensorflow
probability in the joint distribution
class actually it adds a behave just as
if you are using any other kinds of
distribution and that is by design so
which means that you can pass it around
and there are some kind of corner cases
of course it's not completely the same
because the usual distribution it
outputs a tensor when you sample and in
the joint distribution it output a list
of tensor but at least in the API level
it behaves from design they try to make
it behave the same and kind of the cons
is that now you need to have this lambda
function and you don't have the random
variable so if you want to just get one
of the components from the model it's
really difficult
it's possible but you basically need to
run the whole program and then just to
index in to - the list of the things
that you want to basically get this kind
of random variable concept and the first
solution is that you can implement a
random variable class and make sure it
kind of does the right thing a huge
quotation mark so right so right now
this random variable it needs to are you
know in a way kind of like placeholder
so which means that it either has a
property of attention re
or is object behave like a tensor you
can for example over lo is
operators or you can in Heron across
that is a data type Grif order the right
operation operators and you also need
some mechanism to detect the context and
modify the program at runtime and right
now there are quite a few probabilistic
libraries is implemented this way for
example you have pyro you have equal to
is used some concept called handling in
Tyrell and this kind of interception
tracing in ever two but we'll come to
that later you see that they are
actually in concepts very very similar
and otherwise you will need grant over
what kind of theory is a Markov brant
blanket and macro blanket is a kind of
fancy term of all the knows it needs to
carry is parents and these children so
basically we know is that for any kinds
of random variable
who is these parents what is the
downstream a trial and then this makes
sure that whenever in a different
context we can always trace back to the
parents and trace back to the parents
and then run the we run the program
again
so the a bit more kind of like nuance to
that as well there's the additional kind
of cool thing of writing having a random
variable class is that now your program
just looks and feel just like at the
notation you see but the kind of like a
big bird is that it's not really because
it actually rely quite a lot of cipher
which means that you my things that your
program is running this way but it's not
the case there was something really
funny happening underneath depending on
what you actually ask the probabilistic
library to do and sometimes we call this
life via a spooky effect at a distance
because now what user write is not
exactly what we are executing so now I
would go on to explain how we kind of
solve this problem in PI
free in old days well still is still the
same implementations but because the
applications now we need to find new
ways so in in in PMC free we have the
concept of that random variable is
actually a Fionna tensor because we use
Vienna as our computational backend and
we have this kind of like abuse of
context manager because we used to get
complained that all while you're doing
this and we basically use that as a
generation of side-effects to compute
the log prop and we also do some graph
management through taffy a node so it
has some kind of like for example use
via no talk chrome to Chrome the input
of a graph and this turns out to be
really powerful so times III in a way is
tightly integrated with piano and I will
first I'll show you what kind of line a
distribution is implemented in a prime C
3 so we have random number generation is
actually a generator written in numpy
inside pi and we also have a lot of
function and a lot of prop function is
always evaluated at runtime so which
means that we always get back at V a
note answer at the end but the funny
thing is that how we use this
distribution is that if you look at kind
of the met at the metaclass of
distributions actually we always look
for the model context who will if you
initialize a distribution we make sure
that is always under near model context
and if they are created outside of the
model context or the context manager we
will raise an error and then if
depending on the specific we now would
initialize the can apply these Payless
distributions and associated to the
model by adding it to the variables and
here we return either
Barbossa turns from a random herbal and
they are all apply tensor and so for
example let's take three random free
random Oracle as an example so it
basically enable and Assize the log
probability to Aviano tensor because now
we have remedy flight of define a class
we associate all the methods from a
tenth of our goal and we also give with
this property that is the log plot so
kind of the magic here is that we
evaluate the log prague on itself
because now this is the tensor it comes
with some values and when we evaluate it
on itself we build these dependencies
and we can compute a lot prop correctly
so it's all sounds like a super magical
but don't worry let's go through an
example so say that we have a rather
simplistic time see free model we have
some betas which is comfort comes from
some distribution of 0 & 1 normal
distributions and we have X which is has
a mean of beta and a standard deviation
of 1 and we also have some change from a
kind of a deterministic transformation
on a tensor which we just squared X so
on the on the level that the user
actually see on in your Python
environment what the program does is
when it runs is that the first have
generate this variable is a V&O tensor
which is beta and as a side-effect of
the pipe PN top model we will associate
a lot probe to this tensor and then we
have a second tensor is created and now
because it has some dependencies so we
plug that in into the distribution
definition and again we evaluate it on
itself and associate a property to the
tensor and then at the end we have some
other things that is user-defined but
because they are not contributing to the
law prop directory so they are just
floating around we might track it with
my dog truck it depends on whether you
have some prime prime C 3 wrapper on on
top of it and just some quick sino on
contacts manager if this are all seem to
magical and too intimidating still just
remember that when you see some real
stamen is basically there were some
setups and then there's a user code that
been executed and then there's some
additional thing at the end and now we
can we can see how lock prop is
generated so the model now we will
collect all the random variables
basically this means that everything in
the model talked a free of three
variables and observables and also the
potential terms and then we will sum it
all together to get the model of prop
and these are all still happening in
with context kind of like without the
user realizing and that's basically our
model lock lock this is the order the
lock lock information that we actually
need in a bad word kind of computations
and for convenience we also will
actually Chrome the input and flatten
them into one dimension re so it's
easier to work with and then we'll
combine this whole graph into a
functions that we now use it as a color
ball for the computation of blood
products so I actually used two things
that young adult chrome is the things
you must have but actually is not the
case basically the real magic here for
using piano and
I'm see free is that we can compile via
no function and this function is
actually crazy fast so which means that
now we can use this function we can
write everything else in numpy because
this function is just as fast as an
umpire functions right so this is kind
of like all the things of to get the
right law Prague for prime c free but
what about kind of like this forward
generations actually things are much
more complicated in this case because we
ourselves didn't implement any this kind
of random number generation in siano
which means that we actually relighted
on the random variated metro from a
sci-fi distribution and we do some kind
of prop travel show to draw from the
parents and make sure that we do the
conditioning correctly and the big
problem of that is we got a lot of shake
and brokers in issue so at some point I
make the joke that 95% of the the
problems on time C 3 is shape related
and the rest 5% is basically how to
install Theano
and here I would like to keep a big
shout out to Luciano he has been doing a
tremendously great proportion of work to
basically fix our ship handling in
forward random generations so now our
shape error is cut down I would say
probably half and he wrote this blog
post I would share the links afterward
basically explaining why the typical
what the difficulty comes from so in a
way that is not our fault
because the SyFy kind of shape handling
have some kind of lie needs some
improvement because it doesn't
distinguish some of the most specific
shake requirement right so some
refraction is on our side for primacy
free is that by using this kind of
complicated compile piano functions it
allows us to move pretty fast because
all the MCMC method actually all the
samplers are all written in a Python and
numpy this makes the contribution super
easy because everybody most of the most
of us most of even kind of if you don't
know much of light more complicated
frameworks like pianos or 1/10 of roll
numpy something that we are quite
comfortable with and it makes people
really easy to contribute but the
downside of it is that is quite
difficult to take full advantage of GPU
because when we are running some things
that used to be you froofy on oh and
when we do sample in the actually need
to communicate all the the data back to
CPU and this communication is really
costly and we also use some graphs at
editing and cronin to allow us to do
something - see for example for the
vibrational inference we actually makes
great use of that and also relatively
easy to debug because in our case all
the random variable are exposed in in
your environment so you can check for
example what is the tensile under knee
you can check what is the kind of letter
test value that's current covering you
can compile even condition on on always
parents compile log proc just up to that
note and of course the big drawback is
shape issue because actually the funny
story is that we used to have this
discussion to say that all should we
introduce a better shape system to
distinguish when people try to broadcast
and versus when people actually bought
one some kind of independent draw from
the same distributions and this ID at
the time our decision was no actually
just one shape is fine
and now we are basically paying for the
for the downfall of that so as good as
Fionna is the bad new is that is
currently deprecated so after some
soul-searching and some basically look
around of what other alternative we have
we now turn to 10 suppor probability is
a view by Google by the tenth power of
the tensile protein and it comes with
all the kind of necessary component we
need for example it comes with
distribution
it comes with buy attractions which is
one type of transformation but it's wall
enforcer and also it comes with
inference method like Monte Carlo
samples and more rational inference
infrastructures and this give us quite a
lot of new and exciting opportunity
something that I really excited about is
that they have absolutely amazing shaped
system so basically you distinguish
between sample shape add shape and even
sick although I would love to talk about
this but we don't have time so but I
highly encourage you to kind of search
it and see why it's important and why
you should get excited about it and also
it has better hardware support it has
better binding with deep learning if you
want to do patient deep learning knows
easier is under active development and
everything instant graph including
inference which means that now have
isolate acceleration we can do it on
everything there was no needs if we are
running on GPU everything is on GPU
there's no need to communicate back to
CPU and at the time something that I'm
extremely excited about is that they
have they have the sample method also
being in the graph or also be in
intensive flow which means that now we
can have this kind of symbolic samples
and if you write down something like
this you just sample from the tissue so
you set up a distribution you sample
from it and then if you in a session you
can repeat the run this session and
every time you get back a different
result
this means that if you want to run
experiments you want to do this kind of
simulation based method my light level 3
inference is suddenly become much easier
to work with but unfortunately this API
is deprecated because now we are moving
to 1002 however good news is that the
tensile probability team is actually
working really hard to fix some of the
problem it's now have a new class called
a chance from wearable which is used to
call a different answer so the idea here
is that you don't immediately execute
the tensor unless the user as YouTube
and now these things your world
basically you can take gradients of the
random samples and I think you can but
which what doesn't work still is that
you cannot sample outside of a gradient
tape and keep taking gradient of it
because you it won't get updates the
next time you run as it's not in a graph
it's the eager execution hole so yeah so
it comes up with some some new challenge
I mean everything is in the graph so
potentially everything is going to be
awesome and the API is needs to be kind
of this idea is called tensor intensive
out which you always you can you need to
think of it everything input it should
be a tensor and you get the tensor as an
output however this means that some of
the strategy as in time see free is not
going to work anymore so for example in
the early days we were saying Oh since
it's a compiled graph maybe we can do
something similar we can get the tensor
for example the log proc tensor and then
we just do this feed dictionary
basically we can evaluate on a new set
of input however that is not going to
work in 10:02 as well and at the time it
was also too slow so we really need to
think of a new strategy so basically the
strategy here is that we need to find a
way to generate a function which is now
we come to a domain is some kind of meta
program so basically we are not writing
a program to come to walk the graph and
compute a log drop but
actually we are generating the function
and we use that to compute as a function
to pass it around so these come to the
kind of lighter points that people why
nowadays in the kind of the cutting-edge
development we have this thing called it
handling or tracing or interceptions so
in in this context all the models now
you write is their functions because
functions you can basically we execute
it so the idea is that depending on the
context you are running you read execute
program and then you just swap out the
value inside depending on what kind of
computation you do so recall that
because in in the forward context and in
a backward context you actually want to
substitute is kind of tensor value
differently so you still write a models
that looks very similar to a prime C
free model or a model that you run a
piece of paper but now because it's a
function sometimes you don't get
immediately you might not be able to
immediately get these random variables
and to generate a lot of plot functions
for example in advert tool it comes with
this helper function it basically you
pass a model now remember recall that
this is a function and it do some
interception and then you get back a
callable then you now you can pass the
values and the dependency to get a lot
proc so how does it actually works so
this is the this is kind of a cost that
is actually using so I want you to focus
on here so here what it does is that
when you pass you have this kind of
dictionary and it gets the name the name
here is other the names that we assign
to each random variables so because it
has a name now you can do this lookup of
the names and you just walk the values
and you substitute the value here and
and then afterwards you still evaluate
on itself similar to what you might
have done you see earlier in a primacy
free program and you just at the end
collect all the log Prague and then you
do the sum of it and the magic again
here is what they call a trace so the
trace basically is that because it's a
context and remember that a contact is
that you run a user call but every time
you actually do something additions and
this addition thing is what the tracer
is doing so implicitly is swap out the
values and it's it evaluated a lot of
Pro on itself and this is what a trace
kind of program looks like so basically
in a very high level it collects some
informations from the previous
executions so that you when you read are
evaluated you can always kind of reach
an array this random variable but now
with the correct order dependency that a
user actually input and there's also
similar concept in PI Road and they call
it a tracing and the key signature they
use is is this so what it does here it
actually generates this order dictionary
basically it is kind of like tape
machine or tape in not all what is a
sequence of the program being executed
and then they what they do is that when
you're running inference or when you are
trying to do a conditional they will
also swap out the values so here is is
one of the country they call it a
protein and one of the things that they
use is this called replay messenger so
basically you know in high-level is that
it replaced the value so that you
evaluate so it generated a patient
program correctly in this way the
patient program is the is either the in
the forward context or in a bubble
context and then because now the values
are all updated you can evaluate it get
the correct result and this
actually also the in the beginning
approach of what prime c4 is using so we
use this kind of interception but we
give it a really only two contacts so an
eye head word that we have like any
context you want we just have a foreword
context about our contacts and then we
do this replace of kind of lights what
are the values on the run times but now
in the prime see for version two we
actually use something something
different
we now intercept the control flow of
with a Python call routines so I'm not
going to go into too much detail of
quarantine we actually recently
submitted to a workshop of new nibs and
you can I will share the link afterward
if your interest you can have a log of
the paper and what it does here again is
is basically placed on the contacts you
run you want to swap other values so
that is do the same so you have started
out with some placeholder and then when
we will try to see that if we can use
this value directly to interact with the
model and if that doesn't work we will
do something else and you can see more
informations on the link here and again
the key point here is that this control
flow now it's kind of doing the right
thing depending on the context you are
actually asking for because if the user
are supplying some values it actually
reduces computational graph so that you
have the correct lot of functions right
so that's more or less it of kind of in
a more really general way what is the
current direction of implementing a
probabilistic model is basically do this
kind of interception the powerful way
the power of doing that is now is really
Universal and is extremely flexible in
theory you can use any kinds of
background which may
you can use tensorflow you can use a PI
touch for example pyro they have the PI
torch and jars back on and ever two has
implemented tensorflow and numpy packin
but kind of downfall is that is quite
unintuitive so I'm sure that you're
super confused after after that in the
previous few slides of all the handling
and how it's actually executed and even
for me myself I mean on a high level I
understand it completely but if you want
me to debug it is it's a pain because it
does these things that basically some
when you first run it to generate a
program it might not keep you any error
but now but when you actually evaluate
it now you have an error and because
it's this kind of meta programming you
have lots of trouble of debugging it and
also because it has the majority is kind
of like side effects so it's even to the
user if they don't want to know it's
fine but if they want to kind of like
get a better understanding of how to how
it actually works
it seems even more magical in a ways is
kind of like you are implementing your
model but you're not interacting it
directly you are interacting it through
this grub box and just hope that it
works and but there's also another
approaches so for example you can do
something crazy like abstract syntactic
tree so basically now you kind of like
this write a text file and then the text
you you have a program to read the text
files and compile model for you or you
can do grant managing yourself and for
example you can use something like
already a variable on a graph library
and what you might need to do is to wrap
the operators so that you get these
defects accuse and the plus side of it
is that you have maximum control and the
library would be really low level
because you can do crop optimization
yourself and you can do this grab
combination
you know the computation sequence
completely but the dance I said
congratulations you are just really with
implementing intensive rope but all
jokes aside actually we have some
serious effort that leading by Brendan's
on the symbolic PMC which is something
that I'm very excited about and you can
have a look of the repository and see
what is the current progress right so I
think I'm 50% done so so basically now
if you follow this recipe you can
implement library up to 50% and actually
45 percent would be implementing
distribution and by n transformation
like by directions so what are the rest
to do if you want to implement a patient
library is that you will need to
implement inference method for example
optimizers Monte Carlo samples of our
rational inference and you also need
visualization and diagnosis but now we
got obvious so you actually can skip
this part and you also need testing and
unfortunately testing and benchmarking
or writing benchmark model for
probabilistic models they are really
really difficult because you are dealing
with some sarcastic programs so which
means that you get a different result
almost every time you run and so how do
we make can can make sure that it
actually runs so there are formal
validation method like SMC so it's a
simulation model calibrations I think
and also you have this question of
although I see the test or do I not see
the test because you if you see that a
test if the seat is kind of like just
randomly make your test pass then you're
screwed and if you're not fitting a test
then you might get false positive a lots
of time and in general Monte Carlo
central limit theorem is your friend
so way but it's it means that you also
need to run your
example a Monte Carlo sample lots of
times and you if you have an expectation
that is undivided which means that your
screw because you don't have the central
limit theorem anymore and some
difficulty that I encounter for example
is people can be related too much people
I mean me I was related to much on
multivariate normal and especially
directional multi-variant normal so it's
especially bad and also I encounter bugs
that they just impact efficiency but not
the correctness so suddenly your test
you pass but it takes twice as long and
you will just like what and you can have
sometimes you want to implement an
algorithm change but really it improve
improve efficiency and some model but
not the other and you align so nice to
implement it also that I have like more
complicated logic to do this switch in
the middle and also some at least some
of my from my experience that is you
really need integration test and as
early as possible so right so as some
summaries I hope I convince you that
it's quite difficult to write a patient
model in library and the most difficulty
kind of like a 5% of the work but it's
90% of the time you spend it is long
tail even is that you actually need to
think about because the patient program
can be executed in two ways now how do
you make sure that it runs in correctly
in both and we can build quite flexible
framework by using this different
execution but the difficulty is that you
are dealing with this in directness and
but in general I think that it's also
kind of like good direction moving
forward because you can do things more
complicated things potentially easier
for example if you want to have
complicated conditionals or you want to
have this dynamic a dynamic graph now is
much easier right so that's all for me
today I would like to thank the people
from time see organizations that
although all this year working in
tirelessly of building a better
publicity
programming environment and also thank
you all for your attention
what everyone does there is a part that
you don't understand very well I don't
really get why you have to create a
function that writes a function like why
do you have to do major programming to
evaluate the graph one on you can write
directly a function that does it yes so
if you write directly a function that's
kind of like what if you use low level
kind of API does because now you write
your function directly right so the kind
of difficulty here is that you're
actually not writing of so I mean in the
new ways of writing the model it is a
function that you can kind of be pretty
executed but if you want something kind
of like closer to what you see in the
notation which which means that you just
have for example Jupiter cell to be the
cell and to be the noble you write down
all the random variables and then you
just do computation and at the end you
will compute evaluate Allah prop that
means that you actually need some way to
generate a function and that's kind of
like the tricky part because now you
need a color balls that you can prop
numbers in but not just kind of like
that without a dead at that point when
you execute sequentially the log drop
yeah and I know this point is a bit
difficult to wrap your head around
because I think the most the main
difficulty is that when you think of
when you actually write down a lot of
functions you see how kind of like how
different or how not different it is
with a patient model so in a ways that
if you only want the log drop that's
fine and that's actually a lot of things
to do that you just write down a lot
more ability and but the problem is that
when you try to have this higher level
API like for example cameras and it
turns out it's really difficult to be a
publicity
program in a library on top of Karis
because it's all sequential and you also
have line knows that not directly
related your input so you actually kind
of like create this knows our finess and
you you actually need some you need to
influence those notes and they're not
related directly to your input
whatsoever so now you have this
difficulty of the oh how do I keep track
of them and how do i swap the values in
into the graph correctly so that is
mostly the difficulty and and that's
also why nowaday people prefer to have
this defer execution to generate a
function instead I want to block the
ones you want to provide a bit more
information about the you mention about
the central limit theorem for for
testing stuff at stochastic programs
yeah so I mean central limit theorem is
like when you are you compute a means if
you compute with some well I'm going to
be fact-check really hard on this but in
basically it's like if you have some
estimator computing the expectations in
the long runs it will approach with some
count some kind of gaussians and in the
monte carlo kind of central limit
theorem is that you still have some
similar things but the standard error
now is related to the monte carlo
estimation errors so because these
things is gaussian so it's you can now
evaluate it for example what i some of
the tests I wrote on using that is that
I would run a sample us and I'll do
estimation of some parameters and in
this case because I know what the true
parameter is so I just compute like
Monte Carlo errors and then I compare it
with normal distributions and see if the
kind of the differences of the
estimation whether is
within some some margin of error so for
example is it 5% of errors or is it even
more a really small comment for
everybody those that never used by MC
tree have a rough time understanding
these type of things I highly recommend
you check out bias and methods for
hackers it's really easy to understand
in 50 minutes you get how practical all
these stuff is or why this work is to be
really useful when you wanna do
practical stuff
[Music]